dan wage costs and lead position a very
very closely relate or elated I mean
your report really underlines what an
amazing achievement Lester's was that's
right we've seen for a number of years
that the wage bill is a pretty good
predictor of where you're gonna finish
in the league but of course for anyone
who loves football it's it's great that
you can buck that trend so we saw we saw
Lester in that 1516 season we've just
got the figures in on 15th in the wage
table top of the table at the end of the
season ask the Villa a lot further up
the wage table but right at the bottom
of the league and then just in the
season we've just seen you see
Huddersfield getting promoted the
numbers for the season we've got 1516
how does field work fourth lowest
spenders in the championship so they
might have spent a little bit more last
season but but not that much so it does
show that if you get things right on the
pitch you can do that without
necessarily spending the big money
although it's interesting there is a
statistical phenomenon known as
reversion to the mean and the latest
season shows that correlation between
wages spending and position in the
league is really back to how it used to
be absolutely so what we saw last summer
after Lester's triumph was the big six
teams the the sort of the three London
clubs and Liverpool and Manchester
United Manchester City all went out and
spent big in that summer transfer window
would have had the six biggest wage
bills last season and got top six
positions so it was a real wake-up call
for them they were already thinking six
into four for the Champions League
doesn't go and then Leicester came in
suddenly they're thinking well maybe
we're only scrapping for three places if
we're going to have a wild card like
that each season looking further down
the league tables Dan I mean it's
striking the championship and Ligue 1
clubs there's a far higher wages to
revenue ratio than there is in the
Premier League it rather suggests that
the big boys have been manage a bit more
responsibly
well what you see in the championship
particularly is you see people striving
to reach the Premier League that the
rewards on offer the glory on offer
being the Premier League is such a
temptation that people really do stretch
to try and make it up there so for the
third time in four years we've seen
clubs actually spending more on wages
than they're getting in in total revenue
you compare that to the Premier League
where for every hundred pounds they get
in they spend about 63 pounds on wages
which is a lot but certainly not as not
as strong as that's spending in the
championship which is all about people
as I say aspiring
to try and get to the Premier League I
vote briefly Danny looks like Spain's
gonna be wealthier than Germany this
season in terms of revenues yeah
absolutely so we've seen the Premier
League ahead by a long way for a long
while now and the the new TV deal of
course the figures for that to come in
when we published next year but what
you're seeing in Spain is they've
changed their model they've gone from
Barcelona and Real Madrid and everybody
else selling individually to selling
collectively that's enabled them to get
a much stronger deal and will probably
enable them to build a much stronger
league so that's scrapped between Spain
and Germany four seconds gonna be
intense for the next few years but in
the financial terms at least the Premier
League's gonna stay well ahead gonna
leave it there thanks for joining me
good see ya